it's a sad truth but America has become
a nation of Moochers we'd rather sit
around in Mom's basement eat Funyuns and
Hoover up Biden's generous welfare
payouts according to a new study
unemployment benefits and ObamaCare
subsidies outpace the medium income in
several States meaning those folks are
making more dull than your average
firefighter or truck driver for doing
nothing and the free ride gets better in
three states those benefits come out to
over a hundred thousand dollars making
matters worse nearly half of Americans
age 18 to 29 are living with their
parents this is embarrassing uh well I
will start with you uh when we were
young there was some shame living at
home in your late 20s and I'm one of
those guys who moved out really young
like 28.
but honestly do you think we need to
bring back shame a little bit because I
feel like we've collectively as a
society just lowered the bar
if Shane will do the trick bring back
shame because this is highly highly
concerning at a deep cultural level this
morning on Fox friends we had Tony
Robbins on the program and the stat came
up did you know that in 1968 97 of
working age men were either working or
looking for work today that number's
dropped to 89 you say okay 89.97 if one
out of 10 men are totally disinterested
in working you're headed down a quite
honestly it's a path we do not know
where it leads yeah we have had a
culture where women have been in the
home worked in non-traditional in terms
of working Place jobs we've never had a
society where men have simply not worked
yeah what does America look like with a
bunch of men who want to sit around you
want to know what it looks like it looks
like San Francisco it looks like tents
it looks like squalor it looks bad uh I
wanted to ask you this okay but if you
have a point to add go ahead okay what I
was going to say is one of the reasons
that we're having such a hard time with
labor force participation is enhanced
unemployment benefits exactly
um they're almost making it harder on
small businesses to hire because people
want more money but would you argue that
the lesser paying character building
jobs are probably more valuable in the
long run than starting at a high salary
I don't think there's any question but
that the lesser paying job that creates
you know the the essence of the American
worker I mean what we're missing now and
what it looks like we're on a slippery
slope to lose is the idea of the concept
of Merit and initiative and the idea of
Free Ride taking away the energy and the
ambition and the initiative that makes
this country such a great country and
you know it's it's almost like you know
you see this socialism kind of here and
there kind of break its way when this
when you can live off the state whether
you call it unemployment or you whatever
you want to call it I don't care the
money's coming from the government you
don't have to work as hard then what
happens is you know we lose a certain
character in this country and I think
it's it's I think it's going to be very
very very detrimental to this country
going forward it's scary uh JT let me
ask you this if uh the lovely baby Cleo
grows up to be a small business owner
she is going to have a harder time
hiring because the Democrats are you
prepared for the reality that you might
be raising a republican right now
she's one
[Laughter]
interview
we love you I would like to say
something about lifting kids out of
child poverty so I agree with everything
that's been said and I I do think that
some of the blame needs to go on parents
actually for these 18 to 29 year olds
and it actually goes up to kind of
almost to where I am and Katie's a bit
younger than me but mid-millennial even
that there's the helicopter parenting
and the coddling of all this has made it
so that kids don't actually feel scared
to leave the home right and they've
created an environment where it's just
fun to be there anyway but that is part
of this there has been a side effect of
all of these increased benefits that I
think we can all agree is a good thing
so because of the stimulus checks
unemployment and especially the child
tax credit which unfortunately did go
away last year nearly 60 percent of kids
who lived in poverty were lifted out of
poverty in the last couple of years
that's a really big deal and I'm not
saying that means that we should have
carp launch and people should be earning
100 grand for doing nothing but that's a
result that we absolutely cannot turn a
blind eye to listen I I just think what
it comes back to is self-reliance and I
feel like we've eroded that from a lot
of today's population but here's a
superficial question uh back in the day
if you were a single guy who lived at
home with his mom you really couldn't
get women but now a lot of the women
live at home with their moms too but is
the problem still there because now they
have nowhere to go I guess I would I
wouldn't know
um but I do want to say something about
just the the cultural aspect of this and
what people understand about benefits
and getting money from the state and
getting money from the government that
means a fellow American is paying your
way that means someone else is going to
work on your behalf someone else is
paying taxes someone is going to make
sure that the government has what they
need to pay out a hundred thousand
dollars for people so they can say that
they don't have to go to work and this
idea now and this also comes back to
this illegal immigration problem that we
have a lot of people say Americans don't
want to do the jobs that illegal
immigrants will come to do well maybe
it's because they can rake in a hundred
thousand dollars for for not doing those
jobs and there is dignity and work no
matter what the job is and so when you
have the government subsidizing
non-workers
that's why those jobs aren't getting
done and but why people don't want to
start in jobs that make it so you can
climb the ladder whether it's working at
McDonald's or working at a restaurant
like I did or working in a small family
business like like I did and so the
bottom line is that if you're not
working and you're taking benefits
someone else is working for you and that
used to be something that people didn't
want in this country now the pride of
ownership is a big deal just knowing you
made something for yourself like I can
tell you there's a cab driver who drove
12 hours a day knowing I'd wake up every
morning knowing I made myself a hangover
from the stress of the job the night
before but no it's getting out there and
contributing to your own well-being uh
we gotta we gotta run hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else